- And I started the race
to run for Congress.
And part of that reason was
because of Maxine Waters,
trying to get help
with my VA benefits.
I was sleeping
outside the lighthouse
at Ranchos Palos Verdes
and I was going to her
office every other day
trying to get help.
I filled out job
applications, internships,
I even brought her flowers,
and I was met with silence.
And that really made me upset
because a majority of the
people who live on the streets
are homeless veterans and
60% of them are Black.
And so you have
this lady who says,
"Well, I'm pro Black
this, pro Black that,
I fight for Black people,
all of this stuff."
And here I am, a young Black man
and you're not fighting for me.
We have 44,000 homeless
people in the streets.
60% of 'em are Black veterans.
You're not fighting
for those people.
So which Black people
are you fighting for?
(purposeful music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and this
is "The Rubin Report."
We're doing a mini interview
today with Joe Collins.
Joe is a U.S. Navy
veteran and a Republican
running for Congress in
Los Angeles' 43rd district.
Looking to unseat Maxine Waters,
who's been in Congress
for a cool 44 years.
I caught wind of Joe after
his viral campaign ad
that I'm sure many
of you have seen.
So we're gonna show
you just a bite of that
and then get right to
the interview with Joe.
Here we go.
(intense hip hop)
(cash register ringing)
- I'm Joe Collins.
I'm running for Congress
against Maxine Waters.
Do you know where
I am right now?
Maxine Waters's $6
million mansion.
(cash register ringing) Do you
know where I'm not right now?
Maxine Waters' district.
Yup, that's right.
Maxine does not live in
her district, but I do.
I was born right
here in South LA,
in the place Maxine
refuses to live.
Maxine Waters does
not drink our water.
She does not breathe our air.
And while she sits
here in her mansion,
our district is in ruins.
Let me show you.
(intense hip hop)
This is South LA.
I was born here.
I grew up on 104th
and Normandie.
Maxine Waters has been
in office for 44 years.
Has anything got
better around here?
I can tell you firsthand
that it hasn't.
I survived a drive-by
shooting in this house
when I was a child.
Gangs, drugs, violence,
that was my upbringing.
And where was Maxine Waters?
Nowhere to be found.
- Joe, how's it going today?
- Good, how are you?
- I'm doin' well,
I'm doin' well.
So look, you put that ad up
and much like the Kim
Klacik ad, it caught fire.
Are new people heading your way?
Do you feel like you have
some momentum right now?
- Oh yeah.
You know, success leaves clues
and we saw what Kim did
and we absolutely, you
know, did one of our own
and people have been coming
our way for a very long time.
We've been getting
a lot of support.
But I think one of
the biggest things was
we had to actually shine a
light on how Maxine lives
compared to how we
live in the district.
And we absolutely
nailed it with that.
- Yeah, all right,
so before get to a
little of your history,
which is pretty amazing,
and you've done
some great stuff,
let's talk about Maxine Waters,
because in the ad you
talk about the fact
that she lives in a
$6 million mansion
that is not in that district.
If I'm not mistaken,
she's in Hancock Park,
which is a pretty swanky,
swanky area of LA.
(Joe laughs)
Obviously not South Central.
But that she's also
been in business,
and by business, I mean
government, for 44 years.
How did she get a
$6 million mansion?
Which I don't begrudge someone
earning money honestly,
but in 44 years
of public service,
you usually don't
think of someone
getting a $6 million mansion.
- Yeah, you know, she
has a ton of mansions.
And from doing research,
I've seen a lot of backhanded
things that she's been doing,
you know, pocket padding and
all that other type of stuff.
And we have to say, you know,
it has to be corruption.
She's been labeled the most
corrupt politician five times
by the Citizens for
Ethics Committee.
She has her own page
in the Judicial Watch
called career corruption.
And it features Maxine Waters
and everything she's been doing.
She's gotten a lot
of backhanded deals.
She's even ripped off
politicians here in California.
They pay her $45,000
for an endorsement
and another, you
know, 10, 15, $20,000
to get on her slate mailer
scheme that she has going.
So, I mean,
when it comes to the
corruption of Maxine Waters,
it knows no limit.
- Yeah, so, all right.
I don't want to get
too lost on Maxine.
'Cause I think your feelings
about her are clear.
And I have a feeling
most of my audience
probably agrees with you.
(Joe laughs)
But let's talk about you.
Because I don't think
most people think that,
"Wait, a Black Republican
from South Central?
Could that possibly exist?"
Now we know a lot of stereotypes
are being broken these days,
but can you tell me a little
bit about your history?
- So yeah, I'm from South
Central Los Angeles.
I was born and raised there
and we ended up having
to move to Texas
after my house was
shot up in a drive-by.
So I was already in high school.
So I ended up finishing
high school in Texas.
I graduated in 2003,
joined the Navy in 2004.
That's where I
became a Republican.
And the reason why is because
in the history of Black people,
we see that the first Black
men to get involved in politics
were Republicans.
And that's what the
Republican party stood for,
freedom, antislavery,
fight for your rights,
and that's what
resonated with me.
- So what possessed you to
possibly go into politics?
You come back after the Navy
and what possessed you to say,
"All right, I'm gonna
throw my hat in the ring."
- I actually got
out the military
to get involved in politics.
I got an administrative
separation general
under honorable conditions
so I can pursue a
career in politics.
And it was because,
through the 2016 election,
the voice of the younger
people were not being heard.
And everybody called
us lazy millennials.
They called us lazy, they
said we were worthless,
we couldn't do anything.
And mind you, in the Navy and
the entire military in itself,
it's about 4 million millennials
that wake up every day at
four o'clock in the morning.
We do more in between
four and eight
than most people do all day.
And so whenever we would
bring our issues to the table,
they would say, "Wait," or
"It's not your turn yet,"
or "We're gonna take
care of it for you,"
but our voice was never heard.
And so I wanted our
voice to be heard.
So I got out the military,
hopped into politics.
I actually started off as
a presidential candidate.
And, you know, after
I learned a lot,
because, you know,
you can't get involved in
politics in the military.
So I learned a lot as a
presidential candidate.
Then I started the race
to run for Congress.
And part of that reason was
because of Maxine Waters,
trying to get help
with my VA benefits.
I was sleeping
outside the lighthouse
at Ranchos Palos Verdes.
And I was going to her
office every other day,
trying to get help.
I filled out job
applications, internships,
I even brought her flowers.
And I was met with silence.
And that really made me upset
because the majority of the
people who live on the streets
are homeless veterans and
60% of them are Black.
And so you have
this lady who says,
"Well, I'm pro Black
this, pro Black that,
I fight for Black people,"
all of this stuff.
And here I am, a young Black man
and you're not fighting for me.
We have 44,000 homeless
people on the street.
60% of them are Black veterans.
You're not fighting
for those people.
So which Black people are
you fighting for, you know?
And so she has to, she gotta go.
- Yeah.
So why is it, you know,
I'm in LA as well.
And why is it, do you think,
that people in LA, and
really California as a whole,
but I think LA and San
Francisco specifically,
seem unable to connect the dots
between always
voting in Democrats
and things always getting worse.
They seem to not
be able to realize,
"Oh, we keep doing
the same thing
and things keep going
the wrong direction.
Maybe we gotta vote
in some other people."
Have you figured
out why that is?
- I think it's because,
when it comes to politics
and this is something
that I've noticed,
you know, a lot of
candidates don't run to win.
They want to be famous,
they wanna be social
media influencers.
So they don't put in the
necessary work that it takes
to win a campaign, to raise
money to get their messages out.
And so that's what we've been
seeing for a very long time.
People want change,
but if they don't
know you exist,
they can't vote for you.
- Yeah.
So what are the things
that you want to do?
I mean, we all know the
homeless situation in LA
is just, it almost seems like
every week it gets worse.
What are some of like the hard,
give me like three, four
of just the linchpin things
that you want to accomplish
and how you're gonna do it.
- Okay, well, I have
my five point plan
and the reason why I came up--
- I'll go with all
five, let's do all five.
- (laughs) All right.
So I want to rebuild
the infrastructure
to support the expansion
of small businesses,
as well as housing.
I want to overhaul the education
and start rebuilding our high
schools in the 43rd district.
I want to bring
quality jobs back.
Improve the relationship
between the law enforcement
and the community.
And I also want to bring
financial literacy back.
And these are just basics,
basic things that you need
in order to have a
productive, positive society.
So we have to get
back to the basics.
And, you know, you
asked, how I'ma do it?
It's easy.
You just go to work
and you do your job.
And I know that on
a private capacity,
what we've been able to
do with the campaign,
what I've been able to
do in the community,
as far as bringing jobs and
taking care of our community
through COVID-19 is
absolutely possible.
And it's easy, you just
have to want to do it.
- Yeah.
Let's talk about the
policing situation,
because obviously everyone's
talking about that
all the time.
What do you make
about the relations
between the police and,
I hate phrases like
the Black community,
but, you know, with at least
the constituents in
your district right now.
- You know, it's kind of tough
because everybody overemphasizes
the issues of police
brutality in inner cities,
and they ignore everything else
that we have going on
in our communities.
And a lot of times, you
know, when you hear,
"Oh, a Black person was shot
by a cop, it has to be racism."
Even though the cop
was either Black
or the cop was Latino
who shot the guy,
it has to be racist
for some point.
And then they always point out,
"Well, cops did this, and
cops do that all the time."
And having someone
like Maxine Waters
come in to the community
doesn't make it easy.
Having organizations
like Black Lives Matter
coming into the community
doesn't make it any easy
because, you know, if we have
such an issue with police,
then what we need to be
working on is police reform.
We need to get social training
within our police departments.
We need to get better
oversight committees
within our police department.
We need to increase the budget
so we can have better training
for our police department.
And these aren't things
that people are
bringing to the table,
but these are things
that I've been able to
work with the mayor on.
And we were doing
a really good job.
So we've been
standing in the gap
between the police
department and the community,
making sure things stay calm.
And a lot of people
from the, you know,
Black Lives Matter
organization don't like it
because they raise money
off hatred and fear.
But at the end of the day,
when it comes to
taking responsibility
for the community,
this is something
that, you know,
me and my team has been doing.
- Yeah.
So I'm not a huge
fan of Eric Garcetti,
our mayor here in LA.
(Joe laughs)
Do you want to try to sell
me on him a little bit?
Or is this just one thing
you've been able to
work with him on?
- No, I'm not gonna sell
anybody on Mayor Garcetti,
'cause he's never
sold anybody on me.
But I think, when you're
in a leadership position,
it is your obligation
to work with the
people who are leaders
in order to affect
better change.
And I don't have a problem
with working with anybody
if it's gonna create some
type of positive change.
Do I like him personally?
Maybe.
He's a U.S. Navy sailor.
Do I like his policies?
You know, sometimes I
do, sometimes I don't,
but at the end of the day,
if we could take some
type of medium ground
to build some type
of relationships
to improve our
communities, I'm with it.
- Yeah.
So backing up for just a sec,
when you hear people talk
about defunding the police
and everything else,
I've heard, a lot of
people basically say
this is just like
a media construct.
Like nobody really
wants it done.
Is that what you're
hearing from your folks?
(Joe laughs)
- Nobody's going to defund
the police department.
I mean, when you look at
the amount of gang violence
and gun violence,
domestic violence,
and drugs and alcohol
related incidents,
and, you know, all these
cases in our communities,
you absolutely don't want
to defund the police.
The crazy part about it is
the same people who talk
about defunding police
are the same people
who call the police
when something happens
to 'em, you know?
So it's never gonna happen.
It's like a red herring.
It's the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life.
- Yeah.
What do you make about
just the general state
of politics right now?
Not just your district,
not just Maxine Waters,
but like what's happening
nationally, Trump, Biden,
the over and intense focus
on politics all day long.
What do you think?
- I think it's a mess.
I think this is the complete
reason why we need term limits.
We have politicians who
refuse to work together.
Everybody want to be right,
but they're trying to
implement the same things
that they had in
the '70s and '80s.
It didn't work then,
it's not gonna work now.
And we have a president
who's struggling
trying to get things
done for our country.
And, you know, people just
don't want to work together.
So we got to get these
people out of office
on every single level.
At some point, these politicians
should have been aged out
and created an avenue
for new, younger politicians
with fresh ideas.
- Yeah, all right.
Well, listen, I wish
we had more time,
but we did this one on the
fly, just cause I saw the ad
and I wanted to help
get the word out.
I hope to see you
in real life in LA.
Your neighborhood or
mine is fine with me.
For people that
want to follow you
and help you before election
time, where can they go?
- My website is
joecollinsforcongress.com.
You can find me on
Facebook and Instagram
at @collinsforcongress43.
And you can find me at
Twitter @joecollins43rd.
- And Joe, you got to hook me up
with the guy who did that video,
'cause I need some slick
branding like that, man.
- All right, I got
you, I got you.
- All right, thanks a lot, Joe.
- All right, talk to you later.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full
episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.